c'est le directeur de l'institut des
maladies infectieuses qui le dit un
médicament peut bloquer ce virus le m10
sévir avait déjà montré des effets
positifs chez les singes les instituts
de santé américain le tester depuis le
21 février sur plus d'un millier de
patients hospitalisés dans plusieurs
pays fête le docteur fochi est formel le
médicament réduit clairement le temps de
récupération
les patients qui ont reçu du rem d'ici
vire ont passé en moyenne 11 jours à
l'hôpital contre 15 pour ceux qui ont
reçu un placebo soit une récupération 31
% plus rapide de rensing n'a karl angell
et on ne met pas le virus chaos à 100%
mais ça montre qu'on peut le combattre
c'est la société américaine gilead qui a
développé le rem discipline
ces actions se sont envolés ces
dernières heures avec la publication de
ces résultats prometteurs
le médicament n'a jamais été
commercialisée cet antiviral a été créée
pour combattre les mollahs et c'est
finalement révélés peu efficaces mais
sans danger documenté pour l'homme
d'autres fois c'est un docteur fochi
très optimiste qui a présenté les
résultats dans le bureau ovale et donald
trump lui a fait apporter une précision
importante
tony est ce que ce sera utilisé dès le
premier stade de la maladie merci pour
la question ça concerne les patients
hospitalisés en gros on ne sait pas si
ça peut avoir des effets quand les
symptômes sont plus légers au même
moment ou presque
une autre étude sur le même médicament
publiée dans la revue de l'inde cette
annonce une efficacité nulle du remdh y
sévir l'échantillon n'est pas suffisant
pour en tirer des conclusions balaie in
immunologiste américain le plus connu il
assure que l'étude de l'institut qu'il
dirige sera revue par des pairs et
qu'elle ouvre la porte
un traitement efficace si mathieu prost
radio canada montréal